long-awaited event for russian civil
aviation the medium-range ms-21300
airplane made its maiden flight with a
wing solely made of russian composites
the jet took off from the airfield of
the irkutsk aviation plant where the
ms-21 series is produced
initially for the ms-21 wing its
manufacturer used materials from
american and japanese companies but in
the fall of 2018 it came under u.s
sanctions and as a result the company
was unable to purchase imported raw
materials for the wing
our new ms-21 medium range aircraft has
nothing to do with the defense complex
they just stopped supplying us with the
composite materials for the wing this is
unfair competition
they knew we would create our own
materials but that would take time and
eventually we would roll out this new
plane much later
so the russians had to spend almost 60
million u.s dollars on the development
of an alternative to american composites
all the work was done in the shortest
possible time the rosatom corporation
took over the development of domestic
composite materials and is currently
producing them
the ms-21300 is a new generation russian
aircraft with capacity for 211
passengers certification is now closed
to completion and deliveries are planned
to begin in 2022 it is powered by pratt
and whitney 1400 engines and at the same
time the
ms-21310 aircraft with the new russian
pd-14 engine is undergoing flight tests
so in the future buyers will be able to
choose between the two types of engine
there are many innovations in the
aircraft design it has the widest cabin
in its class the ms-21 is focused on the
most massive segment of the passenger
transportation market it will be able to
compete with the airbus 320 family and
the boeing 737 family
according to the head of rostec the
sheriff composites in the ms-21
structure is about 40
which is a record for a medium-haul
aircraft improved aerodynamics have made
it possible to increase the width of the
ms-21 fuselage which brings new
advantages in terms of passenger comfort
passengers have enough room to
comfortably stretch their legs plus the
widest aisle in its class will allow
them to easily pass the service charlie
so pretty soon regular passengers will
be able to appreciate this new creation
of russia's aviation industry jules
pavalova rt
you